[Musique]
là
elle rôle partout aux états unis cette
publicité depuis qu'elle a été publiée
par donald trump sur son compte twitter
donc les chaînes de télévision
américaines qui qualifie de raciste
cette publicité à caractère électoral
on est à quelques jours des élections à
mi mandat aux états unis là pour en
parler
louis aucoin stratèges en communication
et gestion de crise et avec moi bonjour
là bonjour alors publicité choquant pour
plusieurs on nous dit que ces véhicules
beaucoup de stéréotypes que c'est
raciste même selon plusieurs mairies
qu'est ce que vous entendez un certain
c'est certainement raciste ça c'est sûr
mais la caravane arrive tellement un bon
moment pour le président tron on était
en train de faire il y avait la sphère
cash au bilan dans lequel était embourbé
direct et ça lui prenait un autre en
juin pour ramener la question domestique
elysées il le fait que la caravane
arrive au moment des élections mi-mandat
pour le président ça devient ça devient
une opportunité extraordinaire qui le
saisit alors c'est pas élégant mais
c'est pas non plus surprenant parce que
ça fait partie du discours des
républicains depuis depuis depuis
presque toujours de dire les démocrates
laisse entrer chez nous n'importe qui
alors que nous les républicains nous
allons protéger notre notre pays c'est
un thème qui l'exploitent beaucoup
d'argent et l'immigration
ça lui a servi dans le passé il misé là
dessus mais là cette fois ci est ce que
ces risques et qu'il aille trop loin je
pense qu'il vient y vient d'aller très
très loin mais en même temps la question
de la caravane jusqu'à maintenant
c'était de dire est ce que les états
unis ont l'obligation de lire se voir
comment on va s'organiser
comment se protéger est ce qu'on doit
fermer les frontières et lorsqu'il dit
le président et c'est là qu'il va très
très loin et est-ce qui va trop loin
c'est une bonne question
les ce sont des individus dangereux et
ça c est long on va on voit très très
loin et la peur vous savez en politique
et en politique et dans n'importe quel
domaine la peur c'est un des sentiments
qui amène les gens à ne plus lui qui
fait bouger les gens peuvent prendre des
décisions pendant l'élection ni mandat
on est en référendum sur les politiques
de dont notre ambition de répéter sur
plusieurs fois dans les dernières
semaines
alors là on n'est plus depuis hier en
référendum sur les politiques de nontron
on est en train comme citoyens de
prendre une décision si on va le laisser
entrer la caravane ou non et c'est comme
ça que le président vient de
repositionner le l'enjeu de l'élection
de mi mandat et je trouve que cette
publicité là est très très importante ce
qu'ils pensaient pas simplement pour des
questions morales qu'on peut se
permettre de dire de telles choses ou
non mais parce que il vient d'aller
directement touchés ce qui fait le plus
bouger l'aiguillé dans les lecteurs et
toucher sa base aussi être chez sa base
aussi certainement les républicains ont
fait ça plusieurs fois yeux des
commentateurs hier qu'ils aient
rappelez-vous de willow run alors
c'était un autre un autre cas où un
prisonnier avait été remis en liberté
par le programme de libération
conditionnelle et publicité contre
michael dukakis et ça avait fonctionné
très très fort et les pas qui on s'était
posé les mêmes questions morales mais à
la fin c'est l'élection mi mandat c'est
dans la boîte que ça joue et puis la
morale repas grand chose à voir ce jour
là et vous vous êtes stratège en
politique on est à quelques jours donc
du vote ans et marveaux le prochain
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
dans notre homme sort des publicités
comme ça parce qu'il a peur de perdre la
majorité soit la chambre des
représentants ou au sénat
les sondages nous donnent nous nous met
un peu peu au coude à coude ne peut
gérer ça dépend d un peu des endroits
mais c'est certainement que est-ce qu'il
a peur de perdre je sais pas mais ce qui
m'a toutes les chances de son côté
à ce moment ci ça c'est sûr et une
publicité comme ça je vous dise ça va
faire beaucoup beaucoup de chemin et il
ya qu'à voir les médias sociaux pour
voir les gens c'est sûr tu as des gens
que ça choque mais c'est certain aussi
qu'il ya des gens qui n'avaient pas
encore pris de décision qui viennent de
prendre leur décision par rapport à
l'élection
mais par rapport à la caravane merci
fait plaisir